So we've talked about worldviews, but what worldviews should we talk about?
We've talked about what worldviews are, but what worldviews should we actually talk
about? What worldviews are your students most exposed to?
Now there's a lot. We're only going to touch a couple of the most popular
worldviews. And we're going to talk about some of the more dominant ones as well as
what a biblical worldview starts to look like.
But the first one that we're going to talk about is the idea of naturalism.
Now, you can tell right out of the gate probably the idea of naturalism has the idea
of nature. Think of your senses.
Think of the five senses that you have, what you can taste, touch, smell, and feel.
Naturalism teaches that only those things are what constitutes reality.
And there we're back to that word again.
What is reality? So when we're talking about these other worldviews, they're doing
the same thing that we're trying to do.
Trying to talk about what is reality and what is truth.
How do we interpret these things in light of what naturalism actually is?
So those who believe in naturalism are trying to take the five senses and interpret
reality and dictate what is true based on those factors.
That's essentially what they're doing.
And this really, if you think about your students, especially those in public
schools this is exactly what they're being exposed to every day of the week is this
idea of naturalism especially those students that are in stem research type classes
science math etc technology those kinds of things because the sciences are very much
focused on the idea of what we can observe what we can see what we can touch what we
can taste what we can feel those kinds of things.
But also what they're trying to do is they're trying to not only figure out reality
and truth, but they're trying to figure out meaning.
I mean, naturally life has meaning.
And this is where it gets a little bit tricky, is the naturalism point of view, the
naturalism worldview is trying to figure out, well, what does it mean to have
meaning in life?
Well, that's sort of sticky because naturalism actually can't do that.
From the viewpoint of naturalism being told that any meaning in life has to be found
then through science. So science is the only one that can determine what
kind of meaning there is.
But science can only take us through the natural world and
doesn't consider anything else. So we'll get to more of that in a second.
But what I want you to get, though, is that this lesson is more than just
understanding what naturalism is.
It's being able to see that it can't work
and that what we want our students to be able to determine is that they're not going
to get away from it because it's the dominant view of Western culture, but to be
able to see things through it and interpret things in light of it and understand
that naturalism might be trying to do these things, it might be trying to explain
meaning through science and the natural world, the natural order of things and all
that. But at the end of the day, it doesn't really work.
Why?
Well, because naturalism is most closely associated with the idea of atheism,
which means no God, it
cannot explain two fundamental questions.
It can't explain the universe in terms of how and
it can't explain things in terms of why now science is
trying to do this right science is trying to figure out how the universe was created
how things got here and how it is that we're all here but science
can't do this it can't determine why?
Is it just random? And if it's random, why is it random?
We could keep asking that why question over and over and over again.
And to dig a little bit deeper, it also can't do things like determine justice,
love, morality.
How do we determine those things?
How do we bring up the reality that there is justice in the world?
How do we bring up the reality that two people love each other, and that we should
have love for our fellow humans and humankind.
Why is killing somebody else wrong, even if it might benefit me?
Why is stealing wrong? Why do we understand some morals to be
universal for all cultures of all people of all time?
Where do we get these things from?
See, this is where naturalism falls short, because when we're talking about things
like justice, love, and morality, these aren't tangible things that I can grab hold
of. These are not part of what I can taste, touch, smell, and physically
feel. I can't do that with justice necessarily.
I can't really do that with morality.
These are things that are deeper than what is on the surface and require a deeper
explanation. So again it's important for
us to understand not only what naturalism actually is but it's also important for us
to understand that naturalism doesn't actually work so in your small groups
especially in your small groups make sure you take the time to allow students
to sort of discover and discuss how naturalism sort of manifests itself in western
culture what does that look like?
Where do they see that in their schools and in their classes?
It's not just
evolutionary science and those kinds of things.
It might be deeper than that. So get your students to sort of have those discussions
to sort of get them to see beyond just the surface of what naturalism is, and have
them start to analyze it in terms of reality and truth.
One thing great about this Bible study is that we dive into Ecclesiastes and the
things that Solomon wrote. And I think he had this spot on, and it just brings so
much more to the surface when we consider this book in light of naturalism.
He writes in the very, very beginning, right out of the gate, Meaningless,
meaningless, says the teacher, utterly meaningless.
Everything is meaningless.
What does man gain from all his labor at which he toils under the sun?
Generations come and generations go, but the earth remains forever.
And what he's getting at throughout this whole book is the idea that
without God putting meaning in life, life is meaningless.
That all of our work and all of our efforts and everything that we stand for is
meaningless. So think about it from a naturalistic perspective.
Without God, what is justice? Without God, what is love?
Without God, what is morality?
Why are we working besides to make money why is there any non-profit organization at
all why do we care about clean water around the world why do we care about any of
those things because from a naturalistic worldview there is no meaning behind those
things there's no point to doing it because we're all just going to die and be dust
and everything is going to go away and we cease to exist.
But because we have the inclination to want to provide
clean water, because we feel a sense of justice, because we understand certain
morals are universal, because we love one another and we're called to love one
another, we understand that there's got to be something greater beyond than just the
natural world. There has to be the supernatural world.
There has to be a Creator God behind all of it.
So we see so clearly, and I want your students to see this as well, that
when we talk about naturalism, it might sound so easy and so simple.
When we talk about that big buffet of worldviews, it might sound like, oh yeah, this
idea works really well. But when they go down that buffet and they decide that, you
know, yeah, yeah, I believe in naturalism and I don't believe in God, but I believe
in taking care of orphans and widows and providing clean water to children around
the world that don't have it. Those two things are now inconsistent.
Those two things no longer make sense together.
It's a great thing that you want to provide that for those people, but why do you
want to do that? So this goes back to what we talked about last week with the idea
of it has to be consistent. So if you're going to desire to want to take care of
your fellow man and take care of people who can't take care of themselves.
If you have that sense of justice and you have that sense of morality,
why?
Again, it takes us back to here and naturalism can't answer that.
So naturally what we would say is that your worldview then needs to adjust.
So help your students navigate this.
This is a little bit tricky and this, you know, requires some good discussions.
Again, we'll keep reminding you always, always, always let the discussion flow, let
students be honest about what they think, but challenge them in their thinking.